[Music]
Financial crunches happen markets go
down and that happens all of that
happens happiness doesn't happen we have
to make it happen because right things
don't happen you have to make the right
things Fitness is the right thing
doesn't happen you have to make Fitness
happen and if you want to lose any
weight losing weight doesn't happen you
have to make it happen not reacting when
you're angry shutting that Bloody mouth
up doesn't happen you have to make it
happen only wrong things happen
automatically right things you have to
make them happen they don't happen like
that I'll tell you what we all react in
our own ways to lose it not reacting and
shutting this up doesn't happen you have
to make it happen saying a sorry when
somebody hurts you of forgiving somebody
when somebody hurts you doesn't happen
you have to make it happen need
motivation watch a top ten with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best
garugepaldas and my take on his top 10
was a success enjoy
rule number two stay positive I'll tell
you what the nature of problems is that
it consumes our mind
am I in a tooth which is hurting I don't
know if somebody's had their fingers
stuck in the edge of the door and the
door slammed
good Heavens it hurts like hell
and then the pain is just so
all-consuming the mind just focuses so
much on the pain right
I think it's just the nature of problems
that it draws our mind towards them
like the tongue going towards the cumin
seed in my tooth when it was stuck it's
like Gravity the law of gravity if we
put this bottle up and put it up here
and drop it it's going to just be pulled
down yeah drag down by the power of
gravity I think there's a power of
gravity existing within us as well
before us to be dragged down
to our issues our problems
right to everything that's negative
I think be
negativity is so normal it's like
gravity
put this bottle down it falls down you
know how to do anything
but if I were to pull water up from the
ground floor to the eighth floor
I need a motor correct to work against
gravity and I need conscious hard work I
have to bring it there so it's so
natural for the mind to feel negative
and go towards the problem
but if I have to look at 31 other teeth
I have to make a conscious choice to
take my tongue away right if I have to
pull the water down from the ground
floor to the eighth floor I have to put
a pump to pull it up it's not easy work
it's hard work right but hard work pays
off that's when you like look at really
saying okay this is fulfilling me now
you know that and and I I definitely
don't want to impose this this principle
of gratitude in a
in a unrealistic way on people because
sometimes misery is so intense
absolutely
you know when troubles are smaller you
can still consciously look at the
brighter side of life
you know but sometimes troubles are just
so intense and massive and they seem to
be like mountains unmoving unshakable
mountains they just stand there for ages
and decades
how in such a situation wouldn't it be
so violent
to forcefully impose the principle of
gratitude on a person
whose life is so acutely absorbed and
intense misery right you know I call
that toxic positivity
it's toxic
it's not natural so what does one do
really yeah it's just yeah it's such a
situation
when it's just so
overwhelmingly painful you know
my take on it is it's hard to look at
the brighter side when this intense pain
there
but at the same time I also feel if we
are consumed by negativity with that
pain and that problem and it's occupying
our mind
but we lose the ability to deal with it
the way we are meant to
correct so if we could seek help if I'm
not able to see it we could seek help of
somebody it could be professional help
personal help friends whoever it could
be she could seek help to be able to
shift her attention to even the tiniest
things
so that that little positivity becomes
the anchor to deal
rule number three choose happiness how
can every morning be the same how can
every afternoon be the same how can
every evening be the same how can every
day be the same
foreign
[Music]
happy morning
happy morning sir happy morning how are
you doing this morning happy morning
good morning
[Music]
you can say good morning because
sometimes there may be nothing good in
that money
nothing good in that day
so now the term is Happy Money
happy money
because whether the morning is good or
not
you can still choose to be happy right
whether it's good or not it cannot be a
choice
[Music]
good or not for you cannot be a choice
it's not a choice for you
when you wake up some virus may enter
into your head and you get up with a
high fever it's not a child you have
whether the money is good or not is not
in your control whether the afternoon is
good or not is not in your control the
evening is good or is not in your
control whether the day is good or not
is not in your control but whether you
can be happy in that moment well you can
choose to be
when people smile it doesn't mean things
are going good
it just means that they've chosen to
smile rule number four work hard like
sometimes you find child prodigies
you know they're like Masters and
singing or dancing or writing or
whatever they do
you see two-year-old kids when their
hands work go on a piano Spellbound now
don't tell me that he could learn that
and master it in that age
don't tell me a two-year-old can't
master the alphabet
don't tell me that he mastered it by
learning it in fact nobody taught it to
him
he got it
he got it now when you say he got it
don't call it genetic how does g how do
genes give you a music skill
you know how
so I know kids young little kids who are
like prodigies in what they do at one
and a half at two
it's absolutely phenomenal and then now
where is where is faith and belief here
it's rational logic that this guy has it
it's not come from learning it's not
come from Reading nobody imparted to him
must come from somewhere How can there
be an effect Without a Cause
and I can't see an immediate cause right
now so there has to be a remote cause
before this
[Music]
you know what I mean whether I call it
karma
[Music]
it's against my rational thinking you
know so now if this gentleman this
little boy or little little girl he or
she has this incredible Talent
we call it the common parlance is he or
she is God gifted absolutely absolutely
God Gifted Man look at Skye
not learned look at how they're doing it
[Music]
to me is called luck call it Destiny
call it karma Call It Whatever
I didn't get I didn't grab it I got it
Matthew McConaughey
when he got the Oscar
he said something phenomenal I loved it
in fact it's written in the book as well
he first of course thank God thanked his
wife thanked his father thank his mom
and he said I want to thank God
so I want to thank God because
opportunities are not given by the human
hand I didn't seek a lot and it came to
me
how do I explain it
there's a million other people who are
seeking they don't get it that's right
and I don't see can I get it what am I
going to explain it by you know you know
what I mean now what that little one
does with that Talent
or what that what this gentleman does or
this lady does with the opportunity that
has come
is my free will or my choice whether to
drive right to drive left or to not
drive right correct but the car
for a lot of people was given yes
correct now uh that Free Will part is
where I often like to quote I say I
don't know who said it but it's a
beautiful quote it says when hard work
Beach Talent when talent doesn't work
hard
absolutely you know so now the talent
came to you when you were two
you don't do nothing with it
has no meaning it has no meaning so you
didn't drive the car you grossly abused
the Fantastic gift the car that you were
given yes correct and then the others
may not get a car like that but they
have their own
[Music]
their own self-discovery yes to be able
to identify what's the car you've been
given
what's what's it that you've been gifted
with and everybody has been gifted with
something also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five embrace your uniqueness
the one thing that I've learned over the
years is that we are also different our
lives are so different our situations
are so different our backgrounds are so
different our upbringing is so different
the Journey of our life up until now for
each one of us is so different compared
to somebody else and therefore it's so
important that we don't judge our own
life all the lives of others by
comparing them with someone else's life
here's an example
but Mr a can Sprint a distance of 10
kilometers in one hour whereas Mr B
covers the same distance in one and a
half hour which one of the two would you
call faster and healthier
the answer obviously would be Mr a
now what if I tell you that Mr a had a
prepared track to run on when Mr B
drilled by walking on a Sandy path I
think our answer will not change and we
probably think that Mr B is fitter and
let's say we come to know that actually
Mr a is 75 years old when p is only 20.
here we go our answer changes again and
we now think that the 75 year old Mr a
is healthier guess what Mr a weighs 60
kg where is Mr B 125 kg which makes it
really hard for him to run who do you
think did well oh my goodness now we
correct ourselves again as we favor Mr B
the more we get to know about the
strengths and limitations of Mr A and B
respectively our opinions and judgments
about who is better keep changing and
isn't life like that as well guys we
form opinions about others so quickly so
hastily so impulsively so superficially
without knowing much about them or their
situations we end up judging people
labeling people and miss out on
connecting to and encouraging the
immense potential that they may have
is not the same for all some may not be
as talented as others but may get better
opportunities and thus scale up very
fast whereas others despite being super
talented keep struggling just to make
the ends meet
some may have more resources whereas
others can't find any source to fall
back on
each one has different problems and so
no one solution can work for all just
like one size of clothing doesn't fit
all so do not judge others Journey
without knowing more do not judge your
own life by looking at someone else's or
comparing your situation with someone
else's you are you and they are they
your life is your life and theirs is
theirs don't take inspiration from their
journey in a way that you can enrich
yours no always remember life is the
most difficult exam many people fail
because they try to copy others not
realizing
everyone has a different
question paper rule number six live a
balanced life how many of you breathe
I am sorry for asking that question how
many people breathing for the last
couple of minutes as I started this talk
I'm sure all of you have how many of you
are conscious of your breathing
mindful of your breathing I don't think
so any of us
how many of you use an Apple watch any
of you
and do you know that on an Apple Watch
there's a facility which gives you
giving you reminders after every one
hour time to breathe
[Music]
yeah if you use an Apple Watch you know
that it gives you a reminder after every
one hour time to breathe and focus and
being mindful of your breathing ladies
and gentlemen
none of us in the last one odd hour of
shall I say through the day have been
conscious of our breathing
now imagine when you start breathing and
you just keep
[Music]
and imagine if you start breathing out
and you breathe out and you breathe out
and you breathe out can you live
can you imagine our life
shouldn't in such an incredible
sophisticated refined rhythm
the rhythm of breathing
when we talk about life we talk about
we're so unconsciously this taking in
this giving out this taking in
this giving out if we just keep taking
in we choke up
and if we just keep giving out we choke
up
what an incredible balanced life has to
teach us what an incredible Rhythm
simply a breathing has to teach us that
life can't just be a life of takers
where we just keep taking kept taking
just taking or taking nor can life be
just
giving giving giving giving
the rhythm of breathing gives us an
incredible message
[Music]
take in
to give out
have to share grab
to care
that incredible balance that incredible
equation is what makes life
amazing rule number seven ask the right
questions I've done three talks in three
cities in India foreign
like about nine ish I've spoken in
Bangalore in India after that was
overcome to the airport go to Chennai
for another one finish that and come
back to Mumbai and straight from the
airport go to another event three talk
in three cities in L.A what do you if I
snap well
you're technically right I did
but you're practically wrong ladies and
gentlemen
I don't snap like that
you can interact with me all the time I
don't snap like that
I'm a human body and a human machine in
your relationships ladies and gentlemen
I make a humble appeal to all of you and
beg of you life is short
it's very short
don't mess up with people
the closest people to you
give time to them
understand them
they may be you they may have said
something here and there and you may be
technically right okay look at the
Hidden Mango yes your husband or your
wife may not love you and that's
technically right foreign
but there may be a Hidden Mango why find
that out before you brand them
your son or daughter may not listen to
you and you may be completely
technically right that they don't obey
you but find out the Hidden Mango why
are they doing what they are doing they
are doing that is clear everybody knows
it
it doesn't need two pence worth of
Common Sense is it a rocket science to
understand that
is a rocket science to understand he's
not behaving about any damned fool can
understand it
it needs intelligence and maturity to go
behind the technical rightness and look
for the Practical rightness it looks it
needs maturity and wisdom to start
seeing behind the scene to see why is
this person not loving me why is this
person behaving like that why is this
person not treating me right
and if you do that
believe me hand on my heart your love
for whoever you love
will go so deep and your relationship
with whoever you relate to will be so
profound because it's based on maturity
not judgmentalism rule number eight
focus on the goodness there are five
levels of people
on level one the lowest level is a
person who only sees bad in others
For Heaven's Sake that God just cannot
see any good anyone here like that I
don't think so we're not so bad that we
just can't see any good some people just
can't see and you know it's like when
you like someone even if the guy does
the biggest crimes
you like him but the news don't like
someone even if he does the good best
thing you don't like him
and if you have that experience if you
just don't like someone even if he has
all the good qualities you just can't
like him
there are some people on the lowest
level
they only focus on the bad they can't
see the good a level higher are those
who see the good and the bad but
conveniently ignore the good and focus
on the bad
how often it happens when we live with
people there's so many good things in
them but conveniently we neglect the
good things and only focus on the bad my
husband digs the nose okay
[Music]
he digs his nose but he also does many
other good things
you saw that
how come you only saw that you know we
conveniently neglect the good and focus
on the man the third category of people
are those who see good and bad
equally and they're neutral they're not
concerned good bad they're in their own
world
the fourth category are those
who see the good and bad
they choose to ignore the bad or deal
with the bad
and focus on the good
want to like a person you have to be on
level four
if you want to like a person if you're
on level 2 where you're ignoring the
good and focusing on the bad how will
you like that person and how will that
relationship be deep
when you're on level four
where you choose to ignore the
bad or if the need be deal with the bad
and focus on the good and the fifth
level is
those who only see good that's God and
spiritually enlightened individuals who
will only see good in others anybody
here who's on level one only seeing bad
can raise your hand nobody okay thank
you anybody is here on level five only
seeing good if you raise your hand I
don't believe you oh sorry madam I do
believe you I'm sorry oh I didn't see
you raise your hand I was just joking
this joke I truly believe you madam I I
didn't see you raise your hand please I
just happened to save what I thinking
nobody is thank you madam we really
appreciate can we give a loud Round of
Applause for her my God amazing
okay now in your close relationships in
your close relationships how many of you
find yourself many times stuck at level
two
level two where you kind of look at the
bad
and forget the good that they have
thank you
in our relationships we need to come to
level
four rule number nine follow the truth
you know when we're talking about
science and spirituality I I feel that I
never felt there is a divide or a
difference right
I feel the purpose is one
when we look at both having the same
purpose which is to unveil the truth
correct science is trying to unveil the
truth and spirituality is wanting to
unveil the truth so how are we different
in our purpose correct the methodologies
may be different like in science I may
use uh
equipment I mean with instruments and
they use telescopes such as measurements
I may use so many different things to be
able to figure out what that truth is
correct and I will yes I will
phenomenally will correct so from
science and from all what I see
[Music]
but I have facts not complete facts yet
which is why it's always evolving we
call it a relative science it's not an
absolute science mentalif's periodic
table right the values were changing
right we found out the truth later we
assigned a certain value is it sorry sir
this is not what it is this is the
actual value so it's changing so could I
say that this is it may not be if I get
an instrument which is better than what
I have today I'll probably explore
another layer of that same facet right
now that's where I get the facts great I
need those facts when we talk about
spirituality it is giving the purpose of
those facts so we should be working in
tandem spirituality and science science
moment to work in tandem one looking at
unveiling the truth by giving us factual
data
and one saying giving the philosophical
side saying what is the purpose of this
data correct what is the purpose of this
existence and both are two important
Dimensions to the same truth
you know so I I feel that's an
artificial divide it's an artificial
dividend and it's rigidity on both parts
both sides that we can't come together
to sit and say Hey look
I'll give you an example should a doctor
should a doctor repair a car
that's not a skill set
[Music]
should a car mechanic try and do an open
heart surgery no so if I this is my area
of expertise
let me do that much and not delve into
something further okay let somebody else
with this other area of expertise come
together and let's pull it all together
to unveil the truth together
adding our own Dimension to it angle
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is be grateful I
want to just offer to you three
essential principles of gratitude
being Mindful and grateful
the first one being
recognizing
all the wonderful things that have been
done to us
believe me you we are in such a such a
rush most of the time we're not even
thoughtful and mindful to recognize the
incredible gifts that have been showered
upon us
how many of you had loving parents
most all of us
how many of us feel that we've been
receiving so much affection from our
parents yes how many of you have loving
spouses you might want to or may not
want to raise your hands that is
completely up to you it's your choice
ladies and gentlemen where you want to
raise your hands for this
how many of you had wonderful teachers
how many of you had some amazing friends
great how many of you have come in
contact with some wonderful spiritual
personalities
great and how many of us feel that our
life is a collective sum total of the so
many wonderful things that have been
done to us by so many in our lives
show off hands please
all of us isn't it so many of us have
been
recipients and received so much from our
families from our friends from our
teachers from Saints I'll tell you
something to be very honest
what the world needs today
is transformed individuals
we have a lot of affluence we have a lot
of influence
we have a lot of information
we are in an age which is laid Laden
with information
you know what we truly need
is transformed individuals who can
utilize what we have for constructive
causes in the world who can truly bring
light to the world who can truly bring
hope to the world there's enough
information what we would need is
transformation
and what better a way
but to have a spiritual culture
to bring that transformational
individuals and in fact I don't want to
say it but I must but spirituality
happens to be one of those major ways to
bring transformation
I see so many people following different
parts of spirituality and change and
transform to not just be a part of
competition but be a part of
contribution
along with competition they're also
looking at contribution
[Music]
are the ones who can change the shape of
planet Earth who can change the way the
world functions bringing in incredible
hope and light to the world
I must tell you
oh God
just how the world is when you're high
up you don't know what to say there
you're not just I was in America I was
just in America in February I was flying
from uh New York JFK Airport to go to uh
Detroit
and it was an airline called Spirit
Airlines
and in the morning they were selling
alcohol
so I asked the stewardess I guess your
airline is in very high Spirit you know
they were selling spirits in the morning
itself oh goodness
turbulence not in control
take off not in control Landing not in
control choice
in control
the takeoff of life is our birth
no control
I can't change my looks
I was born the way I was
poor family some are born very smart and
handsome someone are bad so handsome
some Affairs some are dark some are
green some are yellow some are born in
the US some are born in Indian some are
born in America Hindu families
some are born in Jew families
what control do you have
over the takeoff
did you choose your mothers and fathers
do you have any control no control at
all and in the landing
death
when does Hope in life
God is the
hope in life you don't have to be
hopeless failure is not the end of the
world someone insulting you is not the
end of the world a Health crisis is not
the end of the world a divorce a breakup
is not the end of the world
foreign
problems during the Journey of your life
from birth to death take off to Landing
as the Journey of your life goes there's
clouds there's wind speeds tremendous
turbulence which is completely beyond
your
control are people in your control
what people say about you behind your
back is your internal control
what people think of you is it in your
country you can try to be good but can
you control people
in New York when I was there recently
one guy came up to me after my talk and
said you're the egoistic person a most
egoistic person I've ever seen I don't
even know him
I'm a human being
even I have feelings and emotions
can't just come and slap you on your
face and I won't even use the words you
used against me straight on my face and
then wrote a wrong email to me that
email is on my phone just in case you
feel I'm Live come and check out God
bashing me with words like oof
what can I do
when a Health crisis comes
cancer happens to someone for no fault
of his or hers
[Music]
winner asks
we all know what can you do
what can you do
nothing right
therefore between this journey called
birth and death there's only one thing
in our control
our choices
the choices we make are completely
in our control choice
however take advantage of the time in
between you know and as I say when
you're born people love you
and when your people when you die people
love you in between you have to manage
yeah
you know kind of really amazing how
people can be of course when we're
talking about measurements we're
measuring in on in one way yes correct
so this the data and the statistics
would be in one space yes so in that
particular space we would say we list
here if we start measuring basing some
other yardstick as a statistic of
measurement probably have a different
whole different statistics available to
us nevertheless having said that I think
uh
I I often say
uh whether you drive a BMW or a
Rolls-Royce
it's
[Music]
it's when the focus shifts overtly to
the car then the journey
you're compromising with your experience
car is important a good car is great no
problem but when your focus is overtly
on that you're compromising with your
journey
I say often it's not an iPhone or a
Samsung it's the quality of your
conversation on that phone that gives
you that experience of happiness but
when your attention moves from the
quality of conversations to the quality
of your phone overtly you're kind of
compromising with your experience
I often say that it's not the watch that
whether it's a Rolex or a desert or
whatever it is you know or uh Georgia
money whatever brand of Rado
or a breedling whatever watch you wear I
really don't think it's the watch that
gives you that happiness it's how you
utilize the time on that watch that
gives you that experience but when your
focus shifts from utilizing your time to
your watch and flaunting that watch I
think we are compromising with our
experience I don't think it's the house
that's made of bricks and cement that
brings us the happiness with the whether
it's in Malabar Hill with the most fancy
Furnishings inside and a massive space I
think it's the quality of our
relationships in that house and
that bring this happiness the home that
brings us happiness so it's not India or
America or any place in the world it's
anybody
anybody who prioritizes things
achievements of things and starts
equating the quality of our their life
with those things okay we'll definitely
have a compromise standard of experience
whereas those who prioritize the quality
of their Journey the quality of their
relation and not saying the things
shouldn't be there absolutely not saying
that I'm just saying equating happiness
to that
is where the problem is where the
problem is because then you know today
and and it also comes from what's
considered a social social standard of
being being accepted as we the social
standard being accepted as cool
today you're not judged for who you're
not accepted for who you are except for
the car you drive or the hope the area
you live in or the class of
uh an airplane that you fly on and a
flight that you fly on so in a in a
society where the standards of your
success are so shallow
then the pressure to conform that if I
don't have this if I don't if I'm not at
this party I'm this form one the fear of
missing out I'm missing out big taste
big thing but who created it the
standard that we made that this is what
happened is me
but if we if we understand that there
are Finer Things that bring us happiness
these things have utility value let's
use them
use the best stuff no problem
use the best stuff who say you don't
have a Rolls Royce but if you think
rolls are always makes you happy I'm
sorry
have the fanciest houses don't have it
what do you think it's the house that
makes you happy I'm not sure if bricks
and cement can make me happy
you know what does someone like you do
to meditate how do you meditate
when I came to the monastery the
meditation I was taught was Mantra
meditation which is chanting on beads so
I chant to Mantra and as I began the
process I realized how
challenging it was
to be present
into the sound of the mantra
and to be totally
in a space in a zone of thoughtlessness
where there's nothing bothering your
mind and you're completely present
and listening to the sound and totally
absorbed you know in the sound I
realized that it was a massive uphill
task and I think it comes that the
challenge comes from the fact that we've
got so used to multitasking hmm there
are mind functions on 20 tracks so when
we're just on the meditation track there
are 19 other tracks to deal with yeah
you know you have your personal life you
have relationship issues you have
professional issues there's so many
things going and if it's just coming
from family
so much going on in the country there's
so much that's occupying our mental
space when you actually want to get onto
the track of meditation by kind of just
putting all of this the back seat it
becomes practically impossible and a lot
of people tell me this when they're
trying to meditate this is what happens
to them and I share my journey with them
this is exactly what happened to me when
I started it's been 25 years now every
single day without one day's Gap one and
a half hours every day
and I and I tell them that it's not that
it's not a challenge today
it would be very high-headed to say that
okay I've reached a state of
Enlightenment when I said for meditation
everything's kind of there and I'm
totally absorbed very high-ended I feel
to say that
but I did a few things that I feel can
benefit those who want to really get
into that a deeper state of meditation
I I look at meditation in two ways a is
the meditation meditation as in the
practice
and B is everything that we do in our
life as meditation you know and I prefer
to work more on everything in my life as
a meditation which feeds into my
practice of meditation but do not
neglect the practice you're not neglect
the practice for sure so uh I'll tell
you what I do for instance uh
one meal a day
I'll just eat by myself
two meals I take with my friends my some
of my monk friends we will discuss
charity one meal is just by myself
the reason being I want to be present
mindful in the moment to savor the
entire experience of touching feeling
smelling tasting that food I avoid forks
and spoons as much as possible because I
want to touch and feel that experience
of the food now the reason I do it is
because it just means no phones no books
nobody to talk to and just being there
eating
correct so what I'm doing is by just
eating that one meal by myself draining
my mind to be in the present like we are
talking now there's three meetings lined
up for me tonight and there's a
restaurant called candy and greens at
Bridge candy the family is a very close
friend you know so they've just opened
up a new rooftop Terrace been getting
message after message could you come
down today evening for dinner all right
but it's not on my mind
it's not in my mind nothing outside of a
conversation between you and me right
now is on my mind so why why do I do it
it's because right now I'm training my
mind to be in the present when I used to
be in the bathroom I would sing like a
big thing for me used to of course
earlier I would sing a lot of Cinema and
movie songs and now I sing some
spiritual songs bhajans whatever and
then one day I realized hey wait a
minute this is not right
because neither am I into the singing
nor am I into the experience of bathing
so if I'm singing I'm missing the
experience of bathing and if I'm bathing
I'm not into my singing so why am I
doing two things at the same time
I stopped singing just focusing on the
experience of the water coming down my
body and
experiencing that so to me these little
things through the day matter a lot to
me and I think that's a that's more of
meditation to me because then what I do
here feeds into my mainstream practice
of meditation and what I do here feeds
into the little things as well so it's
kind of a loop one feeding into other
how do people find that thing how do you
recommend when there's a lot of family
pressure on them how did they find the
thing I find a lot of times it's an
issue with the system
correct like for example uh the industry
the corporate world is only picking up
people from the top rated universities
the industry is only picking up students
who have the best grades
now if you have people who are being
picked up based on your University or
based on your grades and your marks and
your academic performance
then guess what parents are going to put
pressurized kids with you better get
them up you better get the grades you
better get to the best university
correct and guess what the educational
institutions do it's a demand and Supply
system
if this if the demand of the industry is
grades and the parents are pushing to
get grades the Educational Systems are
driven to make kids get grapes now
imagine if the industry changes and the
corporate world redefines saying we
don't hire Grace we hire passion we hire
we hire candidates for their passion
okay now what are the parents going to
say don't worry about the great sir look
at your passion
and what is the education system going
to provide how to look at your passion
okay it's a at the end of the day it's
about the demand and Supply really you
know so in terms of how it is a kid or
how does an individual figure that out
for himself for herself
number one is there is a voice room
within us correct and there's a voice
from within us that's constantly
resonating with our soul saying I love
this you know I may be great at it or I
may not be great with it either or
whichever way but I love this I'm an
absolute love with this I can wake up
early in the morning to do this and I
can go to bed like late in the night if
I were doing this I know that that's
what it's really in sync with My Soul
you know now what happens with that is
sometimes it's multiple things
is three four five different things for
people
right and now that be the case that be
the case then I think it's also over a
period of time we need to funnel it down
to narrow it down to that one thing it's
like it's like being in love right a guy
or a girl is in love with somebody
there's three four different people
they're trying and seeing and they're
kind of exploring which one person who
like really really
strikes that chord so one thing is to
listen to your inner conscience
constantly people who are not in tune
with their inner radar are not going to
be able to find out what their passion
is if you're living a life only catering
to the outside demands and not
introspecting not going deep to listen
to your conscience and your inner voice
where's the question of figuring out
what the passion is going to be able to
see what resonates with your soul do any
of you remember using a rank in an exam
during a school or college days I
remember losing my first rank in a final
exam just by a couple of marks does
anyone remember losing a job opportunity
or a promotion at work and feeling very
low about it I'm sure some of you may
have recall losing in a sports event or
maybe losing a role in a theatrical
performance or maybe losing a sought
after position of power and what to
speak of losing a relationship or losing
a dear one as much as losing something
or losing someone can be painful
disappointing and frustrating just it
just happens to be a part of our real
life in this real world there are things
in life we end up losing not because we
didn't give our best or not because we
were complacent because there are forces
beyond our scope beyond our abilities to
control and it's very important that we
accept this reality never lose hope
the one thing that makes life a painful
audio is hopelessness a boy once into
the room where he saw four lit up
candles Illuminating the space with
their soft glow the first candle spoke
to the boy I am the candle of Love there
was a time when things were used and
people were loved but today things are
loved and people are used to getting
those things no body values me any
longer saying this the candle of Love
went off the second candle said I am the
candle of Peace in a world where
everything is being torn down to Pieces
who values peace and the second candle
went off as well the third candle turned
to the boy and said I am the candle of
trust if there be anything that's really
hard to find in a selfish world it's
trust what's the point in me staying lit
up the little boy started sobbing as he
saw the flame of the candle of trust go
off and the room getting darker the
fourth candle spoke in every assuring
tone don't cry my boy I am the candle of
Hope as long as I am lit they'll never
be Darkness things may be dim but never
dark as long as I am lit you can pick me
up and light the other three candles of
love peace and trust and brighten the
room up again the boy why steers and
with a smile lighting up his face lit up
the room as he lit the three candles
with the candle of Hope ladies and
gentlemen no matter what you lose in
life never lose hope when you want to
achieve success in your career in your
academics in your business in your
profession we will fail and that's the
example of the giraffe
when the baby giraffe is born Falls from
such a high distance straight on the
ground
the mother positions herself right above
the baby giraffe
and guess what she does first gives it a
hard kick
but okay
so as it's just coming out of the impact
the mother gives a bad second harder
kick now the guy understands
foreign
starts getting up on its wobbly legs you
know
on its wobbly legs and as the baby
giraffe gets up on the wobbly like
he gets up and starts running and then
the mother giraffe goes hugs the baby
and starts kissing the baby you know why
because the baby giraffe's flesh is very
soft and supple and hyenas and lions
love it the mother knows that I can't be
with the baby giraffe all the time to go
and get food for the baby
how would I protect it is
[Music]
here
we fail we should get up and we'll fail
again we should get up and like I always
say Don't just go through life grow
through life do you know something in
the game of life you're playing a
cricket match against an entity called
the mind
no one on planet Earth can stop you from
accomplishing and achieving what you
want if you can
bat
against the Googlies
that the Mind pulls at you
how many of you have experienced that
the mild bowls Google is
good
when it comes to exercising and jogging
how many of you know that the Mind bowls
Googles matcha
Soldier
how many of you have trouble in studying
raise your hands as students
[Music]
sap don't get distracted by internet
pornography don't get distracted by
Twitter don't get distracted by Facebook
study don't get distracted by birds to
do bird watching
study all these distractions
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
how many of you wanted to wake up early
in the morning Regents only wanted I
asked
wanted to wake up early in the morning
and how many of you have done something
called as
setting an alarm clock
and then after setting the alarm clock
that's an alarm
whether you want it or not it rings
and when it rings the Mind puts its
first googly
what does the Mind do by putting the
googly makes you clean bold when you do
the first snooze
you are out
if you snooze you are out
I want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the alarm
what happens
you decide to give in to the Mind spot
and this is how your morning Begins by
giving into the mind
[Music]
is
and it's no problem giving in sleeping
five minutes extra no problem the
problem is you develop the attitude of
giving in
you tell yourself that what I decided
last night is not as important what is
important is what the mind says because
we listen I'll tell you something my
humble advice because it's not just
about getting up in the morning it's
about every aspect of life whether it's
your work if you're working whether it's
your study if you're studying whatever
we do
the problem is
it's not about one thing it reflects in
every area of life
is
[Music]
don't allow that snooze what is the most
selfish one lettered word
I isn't it everything revolves around I
I phone
iPad
iPod and the man says I paid
[Music]
what's around the eye
and what does I stand for I stands for
expectations I should be treated like
this I should be loved like this I
should be dealt with like this I should
be respected like this I should be given
these many marks I should not be given
this
you're all leading a life of super high
expectations everything revolves around
my opinions my desires my likes my
dislikes I love this I want this I don't
want this I I I I I I
you think life will be a very happy life
when it revolves around I
from a childhood we have grown up like
this
we've only learned to take and everyone
has to fulfill my expectations
everything has to be up to my
expectations whether when people come to
God people come to a temple also they're
only asking
give me what I want
no one comes to say I love you I want I
want to give you
when the president of the United States
John F Kennedy came up to a stage for
his first presidential speech
his voice rumbled into the public
address system when he said ask not
what the country can do for you
ask what you can do for the country and
so we are saying ask not what God can do
for you
ask what you can do for God but no one
asks that because the eye is so big my
expectations my desires my things are so
powerful that even when I come to a
temple and ring a bell all I'm doing is
asking the more we lead a life of I
or I will always be frustrated
because people don't exist in this world
to just fulfill your expectations
therefore ladies and gentlemen
the most selfish one lettered word is I
which stands for
expectations and therefore avoid this
word
how do you avoid this word
be realistic in your expectations
but understand that not everyone will
fulfill your expectation
and secondly avoid this word I
by trying to serve others
you know why
because when you want to be served
you're dependent on people they may not
serve you
when you want to serve who can stop you
when you want respect people may not
respect you but when you want to give a
respect
who can stop you when you want to be
loved
you may not be loved but when you want
to give love who can stop you when you
want and charity people may not give you
in charity but when you want to give
charity who can stop you and therefore
learn
to begin your journey from I
to you the more you want for yourself
you'll remain frustrated the more you
want to give
you will remain happy there is a concept
called sledging in cricket where the
opponent team comes and gives garly to
the breadsmen
garly they try to
eat them
their focus away one thing that Sachin
is adored for
in the history of cricket is sledging
hasn't bothered him
this man is cool
are you cool when people do sledging
against you in The Game of Life
are you cool
or you lose your cool there will always
be people who are out of control
can you stop a guy
it's called things which are out of our
control people are out of our control
sometimes our situations in your control
many times
foreign
ball
[Music]
and that's what the bowler bowled
and one gush of wind an in-swing becomes
an outswing
and is caught out
a lot of things situations people are
just out of our control how many of you
think question paper is in your control
and when things go wild nah I'll tell
you what happens with us
this is what happens with us
[Music]
see how it comes up
we react
the stimulus of
a person sledging against us criticizing
pulling us down envious of us conspiring
politicking
makes us react and form out right
whoever we start reacting also
foreign
[Music]
the question is do you want to be a 7UP
can
or a oxicle bottle of water and I'm sure
a lot of us would say
um
and thus in our life we will always have
a stimulus
and we can choose to respond because
between the stimulus and response is our
choice
[Music]
the maternity what
a great personality is born by the
choices that one makes
[Music]
and therefore when there are all kinds
of stimuli we have to learn how to
respond
if we are not strong spiritually it is
impossible
if we are not strong culturally it is
impossible all this sounds great and
good and we know yes but I want to do it
I can't be a can of soda I want to be a
water bottle but is it so easy
no
that is why coming here is so important
that is why this foundational ethics of
spirituality are so crucial in this age
as all of you
are going to be successful in your own
areas of life if not Cricket per se
and thus we have to learn how to respond
reading inspirational and motivational
books uh and I also think because the
online world is so big today the online
platform is so big today whether it's
Facebook whether it's Instagram whether
it is Twitter whether it is YouTube this
massive platforms but there's so much
material available so much motivational
stuff available so much inspiration
available as soon as we feel low we may
have our choice speakers we may have our
choice gurus the men who have Choice
experts by listening to whom we feel
motivated by listening to whom we feel
uplifted by listening to whom you feel
energized
we should regularly on a proactive basis
listen
to
podcasts watch
videos
or read books
that can keep us going this is of course
not when you have when somebody goes to
the extreme end of ending their lives
can't read a book or watch a video there
but that did happen we posted a video on
Facebook this reposted a video this
morning where we were talking about an
individual who wanted to give up his
life in Cincinnati Ohio in the United
States of America he was a university
student and as he was in
that moment of committing suicide
hanging himself in his head is
and there was a notification on his
phone a WhatsApp notification the guy
happened to see that notification it
happened to be one of the videos we had
made
and he watched those videos for four to
eight hours non-stop all online stuff
available from our channels
online
and decided
I shouldn't commit suicide
decided to keep going which is why I
think that the third thing to boost a
coping mechanism is to look at online
motivational material as well it's a
proactive thing to constantly keep
looking for good material so that we
feel inspired motivated challenges and
problems are going to be there for
everybody like I said earlier but we'll
be stronger to face that
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Jay Shetty check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there when you protect your
purpose your purpose protects you now I
want to unpack that what I mean by that
is your purpose is like a rare Jewel and
a red gemstone and